the original God of War was quickly
heralded as one of the finest action
games of its time of course this led to
a franchise of sequels and spin-offs
many of which are considered
masterpieces by critics and fans alike
while many praised the much improved
storytelling with 2018's God of War it
was the bloody and unrelenting action
that earned the originals their place in
gaming history fueled by kratos's
ever-growing hatred for anything that
stood between him and revenge each God
of War game is littered with boss fights
of Epic scale guaranteed to send you on
a massive power trip today we're taking
a look back at some of the very best
boss battles this revered action Series
has to offer as I share my picks for the
top 10 bosses in the God of War
franchise
foreign
the Hydra when the first God of War Game
begins Kratos is deep in servitude to
the other Greek gods hoping that his
service will rid his mind of the
troubling visions that have haunted him
for years hardened by Decades of battle
Kratos is already an immensely powerful
fighter clearly evidenced by the legions
of bodies left in his wake when we first
meet up with him he's sailing through
some seriously Rough Waters in pursuit
of the mythological Hydra a three-headed
serpent that he must kill to appease the
god of the sea Poseidon the Hydra is the
very first boss fight of God of War and
serves as a perfect introduction to the
signature spectacle that the franchise
has since perfected after bursting
through the floor of the ship and
chomping down on the captain the Hydra
sets its sights on Kratos with a flurry
of attacks and a bit of magic Kratos
ultimately kills the Beast by skewering
its head on the spiked Mast of the ship
it's certainly not one of the most
challenging bosses of the series but its
magnificent sense of scale and gory
finish serve as one of the most
memorable in the entire franchise and
helps set the stage for what's to come
number nine Aries there are quite a few
Greek deities on kratos's seemingly
endless list of enemies to defeat but as
the primary cause of his pain and
suffering Ares is the main target for
the majority of the first God of War
game as the Greek God of War Ares is a
biamoth of Doom and death but that
doesn't dissuade Kratos during his
destructive tour for Revenge after
battling his way across Olympus and
unearthing Pandora's Box which grants
him the power to kill a god Kratos
finally gets his duel with Ares in the
climactic battle of the first game set
in the middle of the war-torn city of
Athens the boss fight against Ares was
as satisfying as it was spectacular with
Kratos utilizing Pandora's Box to grow
to an enormous physical size matching
him with Aries now finally standing
toe-to-toe with his fiery Nemesis Kratos
engages Aries in a vicious fight to the
death although Ares does get in a bit of
damage against Kratos it's simply not
enough to overcome kratos's rage he
ultimately lands the killing blow with
the giant blade of the Gods and then in
an ironic twist killing Ares actually
earns Kratos the throne as the new God
of War turning the Furious Warrior into
the one thing he despised the most I was
trying to make you a great warrior
you succeeded
number eight Kronos in God of War 3
Kratos wages an all-out war against the
gods of Olympus with the aid of the
Titans truly massive creatures that make
Ares and the other baddies look like
ants in comparison while some of the
Titans are more than willing to help
Kratos on his Path of Revenge there are
a few that end up on our anti-heroes bad
side this is true of Cronus a Titan who
is forever imprisoned in the abyss of
Tartarus and guards an ancient Relic
known as the amphilis stone when Kratos
requires the stone to further his war
effort Kronos becomes a necessary
casualty in the equation the fight
against Kronos feels much more like a
fight on Kronos as Kratos must Traverse
the enormous Titan fending off lesser
enemies along the way as Kronos swats at
Kratos like an irksome fly the warrior
does everything in his power to inflict
maximum pain even prying off some
fingernails in the process even after
the Titan picks up Kratos and swallows
him whole the warrior cuts his way out
from the inside setting up a killing
blow right between the eyes simply we
put the fight against Kronos proves that
size is barely a contributing factor
when it comes to kratos's ability to
kill it
number 7 balder in God of War 2018
Kratos does his best to end the cycle of
Bloodshed by journeying to the Norse
realm of mitgard where he attempts to
raise his young son atreus as expected
this period of Peace only lasts so long
as he soon faces off against an
assortment of legendary Norse figures
one of the most prominent foes who
crosses his path is balder the son of
Odin the all father and the Sorceress
Freya enchanted with an invincibility
spell by Freya in an effort to prevent
his death Baldur is a ravenous ball of
resentment unable to feel pain pleasure
or anything in between although Kratos
and balder have quite an explosive Duel
at the beginning of the game their final
Face-Off occurs at the climax of the
story when balder attempts to kill Freya
and answer to his unfeeling existence
seeing a reflection of his own tragedy
playing out in front of him Kratos tries
to kill balder after atreus stabs him
with an enchanted Arrow which reverses
his invincibility and renders him mortal
even as Freya uses her magic to
resurrect a fallen Titan to impede
Kratos the fight ensues and all
ultimately leads to balder's death in
addition to being one of the most
riveting fights in the game the battle
with balder is also a pivotal point in
the narrative as Kratos finally shares
his troubled history with his son
number six Hercules during kratos's
Ascent to the top of Mount Olympus in
God of War 3 he spills the blood of
several over confident deities in his
quest to kill his father Zeus arriving
at The Forum he is greeted by Hera who
refuses his requests and sends the
powerful Champion Hercules to take him
on Arrogant with strength and jealous
that his half-brother Kratos has become
the god of war while he toils away on
Olympus Hercules holds nothing back in a
bloody fight for the ages the battle
against Hercules is both chaotic and
challenging as Kratos must fend off
dozens of Hercules minions while also
enduring quips from the drunken Hera who
watches from the balcony above even
after Kratos strips Hercules of his
Hefty gauntlets and leaves him bruised
and broken he refuses to back down
forcing our hero to beat his face into a
bloody pulp in a franchise that is full
of remarkable over-the-top violence the
death of Hercules is by far one of the
most gruesome moments making it very
hard to forget plus you get to keep his
gauntlets in the end expanding Your
Arsenal and enabling even more face
smashing in the fights to come
number five Poseidon while Poseidon
makes a few appearances in the first two
games it's in God of War 3 where the god
of the sea finally faces the wrath of
Kratos at the very beginning of the game
as Kratos rides the Titan Gaia up Mount
Olympus Poseidon attempts to stop their
assault but quickly learns he's no match
for the new and improved God of War
wielding a huge Trident and riding on
the back of a multi-headed horse Beast
made of water Poseidon has a lot of bark
but lacks the bite to back it up however
like the battle against Kronos it's hard
not to fall in love with the pure
spectacle and scale of this fight after
a quick tussle Kratos manages to knock
Poseidon out of his ocean form and
proceeds to thrash him within an inch of
his life thanks to some creative use of
the camera here we witnessed this
ruthless beat down through Poseidon's
eyes as Kratos maims and disfigures him
being the first boss fight in God of War
3 this clash with Poseidon firmly raises
the bar and establishes an undeniable
tone of brutality that persists
throughout the game
thank you
number four sigren the valkyrie Queen
while there are more than enough bosses
to slay in God of War 2018 sigrin the
valkyrie Queen exists as an optional
boss fight for players who really want
to test their skill to unlock this
extremely tough battle you'll have to
defeat the eight other Valkyries
scattered around midgard then bring
their helmets to the Council of
Valkyries as an offering once placed on
their respective Thrones sigrin appears
ready to punish Kratos over and over
again while sigrin might not be a
towering monstrosity or a God of Olympus
she stands out as one of the most
challenging bosses in any God of War
Game possessing the unique abilities of
all eight prior Valkyries and hitting
twice as hard zigrant will take every
ounce of strategy and skill you have to
defeat her she's agile unpredictable and
quick enough to catch you with
counter-attacks fighting sagrin offers
very little room for error besting this
incredibly deadly boss is a feat
reserved only for the most patient and
skilled players around and once you
finally two finish her off the feeling
of reward and satisfaction is pure Bliss
and probably one that is unmatched in
any other God of War game
number three Hades
[Music]
after falling for Mount Olympus and into
the underworld Kratos is in a
particularly bad mood even for him so in
Hades Corners him and attempts to steal
his soul you know things are going to
get rough with most of Hades his
relatives and loved ones already
massacred at the hands of Kratos the god
of the dead has very little to lose and
throws everything he has into this
bitter fight to the end starting the
fight with his ominous opening monologue
and ending with Kratos literally ripping
out his soul the fight with Hades is a
perfect representation of what makes the
God of War Series so enthralling the
visual design of Hades is incredible his
voice sounds like a mixture of gravel
and pain and then a battle that's just
as bloody as they come even for God of
War throughout the fight Kratos rips off
hades's armor piece by piece eventually
disarming him and then using his
soul-rending claws to rip open his head
Yes you heard me correct which unleashes
thousands of tormented Souls when it
comes to powerful protagonists there are
very few that have ventured through the
underworld and slayed its overseer
putting Kratos in a league of his own
and thus cementing this boss fight as
one of the most memorable in any God of
War Game heck in any video game
throughout history
number two the sisters of fate
there is
here
will die
for God of War 2 the developers wanted
to go bigger and better in every way and
kratos's fight against the sisters of
Fate is a stunning example of their
overwhelming success after Zeus quite
literally kills Kratos and sends him
sprawling into the Underworld the
anti-hero looks for a way to reverse his
downfall which ultimately lead him to
the three sisters of Fate hidden on the
island of creation these Destiny weaving
siblings control the very fabric of time
itself making them yet another
significant obstacle in kratos's quest
for Revenge after hitching a ride on a
phoenix and landing at their front door
Kratos confronts the first two sisters
who refuse to bend Fate To His will but
it's really the mechanics of this boss
fight that make it Stand Out Among the
others in the series this is not an easy
fight it also has multiple phases and
the sisters also seem to get better at
parrying as the fight goes on Midway
through the fight lackasis will summon
her sister atropos for help you'll then
find yourself transported back to
kratos's climactic battle with Ares at
the end of the first game Kratos lands a
big blow on atropos which transports him
back to the Temple of Fates for the
final part of this insane Battle of
course now the sisters are really angry
and you'll have them both attacking at
the same time fortunately atropos is
stuck behind the mirrors and can only
attack from there while this boss fight
doesn't have that huge sense of scale
that some of the other god of war fights
do it's those ever-changing mechanics
that always keep you on your toes
throughout this fight that I think make
it stand as one of the best in the
series
[Music]
number one Zeus
foreign
[Music]
Zeus at the end of God of War 3 he is
still hungry for more Vengeance casting
aside almost every Ally he has met along
the way he stands alone facing down his
father and the final Target on his list
of gods to kill as the leader of Mount
Olympus and all the other gods Zeus is
the most formidable Foe and kratos's
long and treacherous Journey resulting
in a battle for the ages as the
climactic fight for not only God of War
3 but the end of the original God of War
Trilogy the final fight with Zeus checks
every box on my boss fight wish list
after their brawl spills out onto the
top of Mount Olympus the Titan Gaia
reappears and tries to enter the fight
but Zeus and Kratos end up using her as
a Battleground instead even when Kratos
impales Zeus and cripples his physical
form the king of all gods lashes out at
him in spirit form which sends him
spiraling down deep into his own psyche
experiencing visions of his slain wife
and child Kratos finds the power to
forgive himself before returning to
Consciousness to end Zeus once and for
all and thus cementing himself as a true
Contender for one of the most ruthless
protagonists in all of gaming Kratos
forced Zeus's Spirit back into corporeal
form and doesn't stop punching until his
vision is blurred with gallons of blood
[Music]
if you're a fan of Kratos in his quest
for revenge against the gods of Olympus
then you should definitely check out The
Iliad by Homer and thanks to audible.com
today's sponsor you can download the
audiobook version with a free 30-day
trial of audible Premium Plus by
visiting audibletrial.com retro you can
keep the audiobook even if you cancel
your trial early The Iliad is a classic
Greek tale about the city of Troy and
features the likes of Achilles Agamemnon
and Odysseus who are in a fight over
Helen a daughter of Zeus who's been
abducted by a Trojan here's an excerpt
from the audiobook which is narrated by
Dan Stevens Agamemnon now I take it the
siege is broken we are going to sail and
even so may not leave death behind
if War spares any one disease will take
him
we might though ask some priest or some
diviner even some fellow good at dreams
for dreams come down from Zeus as well
why all this anger of the god Apollo if
you're already an Amazon Prime member
you'll actually receive two audible
credits with the trial and even if you
aren't a Prime member you can still use
my link to get the Iliad or any other
audiobook of your choice completely free
if you're interested you can type out
the URL on your screen now or find it in
the video description below as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon
You Are Not Alone